ينضم الينا الان من مستشفى الشفاء في
مدينه غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول
اسماعيل اطلعنا على اخر التطورات لديك لا
سيما في ارتفاع اعداد الشهداء في قصف ربما
ليس بعيدا عنكم في حي الشيخ
رضوان صحيح يتواصل القصف الاسرائيلي في كل
ناحيه وفي كل منطقه في مدينه غزه لكن الان
اصبح او بات لا يمكن حصرها عدد الشهداء في
مختلف مناطق مدينه غزه بسبب القصف العنيف
والمتواصل على مختلف المناطق وانقطاع
التواصل ما بين منطقه واخرى واصبح حتى دفن
الشهداء في نفس المنطقه التي يقصف بها
الشهداء لكن الكارثه الكبرى الذي يتعرض له
القطاع الصحي في هذه المنطقه هو صباح
اليوم ارتقى ثمانيه شهداء متاثرين بجراحهم
بسبب عدم وجود كوادر طبيه كافيه وعدم وجود
ادويه لازمه وهذه المره الثانيه الذي
يزداد فيها عدد الشهداء ويوما بعد يوم
يزداد الشهداء بعد اصابتهم اصابات بغه من
قوات الاحتلال ي تعجز الطواقم الطبيه عن
اجراء عمليات وتقديم العلاج اللازم لكن في
الساعات الاخيره ايضا قصفت قوات الاحتلال
منزل ابو حازم الدلو الذي اسفر عن او وقع
في داخل هذا المنزل 12 شهيدا وما زالوا
تحت الركام تم انتشال بعض هؤلاء الشهداء
ولكن الكثير بقيوا تحت الركام بالاضافه
الى ذلك قصف قوات الاحتلال لعدد من
المنازل في منطقه الصحابه ومنطقه اليرموك
هذه المنطقه التي هي تعتبر منطقه مصرح
عمليات لقوات الاحتلال وتتواجد قوات
الاحتلال بكثافه في تلك المنطقه بعد
انسحابها من منطقه ابو اسكندر
وانسحابها من منطقه مسجد التقوى هذه
المناطق التي كانت مصرح عمليات قبل ايام
وبالامس قوات الاحتلال اجلت جميع
المواطنين المتواجدين في منطقه ابو اسكندر
والمواطنين المتواجدين في مدرسه عمرو بن
العاص هذه المنطقه التي تتواجد في منطقه
ابو الامين ومنطقه ابو اسكندر الان تنتقل
عمليات قوات الاحتلال الى منطقه شارع
اليرموق ومنطقه عبد العال والمناطق
المحاذيه لهذه المناطق هذه هي مصلحه
العمليات وقصفت قوات الاحتلال عدد من
المنازل واستشهد عدد من المواطنين من
عائله الايوبي بالاضافه الى عائله العقيله
التي دمر منزلها فوق رؤوس ساكنيها وابلغ
المواطنون الذين قدموا من تلك المنطقه ان
ان لم يستطيعوا انتشال اي من الشهداء
واستطاعوا اخلاء تلك المنطقه بنجاح
وحافظوا على ارواحهم رغم اطلاق قوات
الاحتلال النار الكثيف على المواطنين خلال
اخلاهم وتحذيرهم بطائرات الاستطلاع بالقصف
المستمر شكرا لك اسماعيل الغول من مستشفى
الشفاء في غزه
b